[Music]
i am jonathan graham and i am the
chocolatier and owner of compartes
chocolate and i'm going to be your
expert for valentine's chocolate um i've
probably never eaten chocolate like this
before so you're going to be on an
adventure with me
it certainly didn't smell chocolatey it
smelled sugary you know what else i i
hate not knowing
this tastes like
the candy that you would get when you
were a little kid you know it's fun it's
candy it's in a heart-shaped box
we've gone a lot bigger as you can see
just from the plate no guide i'll say it
does look nice that there's white
chocolate milk chocolate dark chocolate
so if you don't know what the person
likes you've got a good variety box in
here
this is better than the previous ones i
might even actually just taste another
i don't know what that one is but it's
got some crunch to it there was a snap
on the chocolate is if you want
chocolate you should actually go for
chocolate again dark chocolate high
cocoa content i think this would be a
good gift to give if you were you know
21 but if you're 30 you need to step up
your game
the most happy this makes me is that
there's a guide because that means at
least i can kind of see what i want to
go with instead of mystery chocolate one
that says honey buttery
caramel no snap on this chocolate it's
not honey it's not buttery this type of
caramel and this type of consistency
means preservatives that really makes me
depressed right because all the other
boxes i didn't know what i was getting
and now the one that i really wanted is
such a letdown
the caramel consistency is really nice
it's a nice deep caramel color the milk
chocolate shell is so thick they've
lathered on so much milk chocolate that
it overpowers the caramel you're just
gonna give your valentine milk chocolate
go buy a milk chocolate bar
this the milk chocolate quality of this
product is the best of the quality that
we've tried i like the butteriness and
consistency on the inside of this this
is more of a true truffle because it has
a creamy chocolate center this one's
okay it's not great but it's much more
in line with with my taste and higher
end chocolate than what we've been
tasting previously
again a lot of the pieces we saw before
very generic looking this is prettier
not bad
it had the snap i don't know if you
heard it it's really plain and milk
chocolate and simple but it's it's okay
i'm not mad at it
if you can't afford a really big box of
chocolate get a smaller box that's good
i think that when you're giving a
valentine's gift it needs to be unique
you have one day a year to show yourself
you could screw up the chocolate and be
sent home what about making something at
home you could just buy chocolate and
melt it down and get some strawberries
and dip them and that's so much more
unique and special i just love the
candle and champagne setup
you're gonna get chocolate candle
shampoo and we're just missing the
flowers but you know flowers die
and chocolate lives forever
or until you eat it